great second half
appreciate it
how does it feel to have two running
backs over a hundred yards today yeah
it's great uh it really is that really
is great i mean credit the offensive
line credit those two guys creditor
receivers out there blocking
the play calling just a compliment um to
have two two bags both rushed for 100
yards uh that's great i mean that's
that's complimentary still a line like i
said just really the whole offense
dak prescott after the big victory 31-6
quite a statement for the cowboys who
are three-and-oh and on their way and
yes they are hey the eagles are one and
two the giants are one and two
washington is owen two and quite
possibly on the way to owen three
cowboys running away potentially with
that division yeah yeah well the cowboys
are a special football team and the
eagles have not played as well as we
have thought uh you know whether it's uh
the loss last week the injuries of
course yesterday to the lions uh so the
cowboys are set up right now to kind of
put a stranglehold on the nfc east are
you ready good sir trivia question let's
do it to determine the first pick in the
sunday statement draft patrick mahomes
has the fourth most passing yards ever
through three weeks of a football season
name any of the quarterbacks who are
ahead of him on the all-time list most
passing yards through the first three
games of a season you just have to name
one of the three oh gosh you know what's
crazy is i feel like my dad might be
part of this conversation i'm gonna go
with peyton manning just to be safe oh
no
tom brady in 2011 right ryan fitzpatrick
last year is number two
and your good friend kurt warner
2 000
patrick last year i totally forgot yeah
he was on fire during the uh it was
during the
um
jameis winston suspension and obviously
fits magic became fits tragic as it
tends to do
all right first pick for me uh look i
bigger picture new orleans saints
smaller picture alvin kamara right you
you don't need to to lean on the
quarterback position when you have a guy
who is one of the most dangerous weapons
in all of football they don't overuse
him but they use him enough to get it
done and without him yesterday the
saints don't win that game yes they only
had 265 yards of offense but at the same
time with camara he helps you get
through this storm without drew brees
and that's the challenge for the saints
how many games can they get through with
victories this is one they stole that
that we did i thought they had no shot
and they they took it and having camara
and having him healthy and having him
getting things done it was you know 69
yards
rushing but 92 receiving on those nine
receptions from teddy bridgewater he can
make things happen make people miss look
at that just and ends up with the
walk-in touchdown after weaving through
traffic and bouncing off of guys you
have him and you're gonna be okay no
matter who the quarterback is yeah i
mean that was a huge statement for that
whole football team i mean alvin kamara
the saints whatever it may be and it's
just amazing uh whether it's drew brees
or teddy bridgewater the amount of plays
i see every week where it's hey
quarterback just look down here i'm
going to send a bunch of other people
but the play is really for alvin kamara
right here everything's window dressing
just to throw the go so we look we go oh
wow what a great read by the quarterback
and i want to go no he literally was
said just throw to this guy it's the
only guy we're even calling this play
for i'm amazed with all the ways that
sean payton finds uh on a weekly basis
to get alvin kamara that was a huge
statement for them in that football game
so yeah i'm with you as far as sunday
statements are concerned hey let me let
me ask you one question
isn't it weird tasting hill didn't throw
a passion yeah it is weird i did i
thought it was weird that he didn't have
any role but i i guess again i guess
what um we're we're seeing is he's you
know maybe a little bit scared to throw
him in there because he is the true
backup now he doesn't have that little
flexibility to go well he's really the
third stringer so i can put him in here
and there you know now he's really going
to save him just in case teddy does get
a point or something like that i'm
guessing i don't know that but i guess
that's my logic there
as far as sunday statements go i think
other than the new orleans saints the
second biggest sunday statement is the
detroit lions i'm just going to give
them i mean there they are the
undefeated detroit lions and yeah one of
those games is a tie on the road against
arizona but i mean to go into
philadelphia yesterday and win that
football game i i think that says a lot
about the direction this lions football
team is going and again i don't know if
they're a playoff football team the nfc
north is very competitive and those are
some good football teams but either way
matt patricia has changed the culture uh
in detroit as we talk about so much you
know i mean and it was a tough change of
the culture i mean the way they play
football now smash mouth football tight
end over the middle you know taking
shots down the field with with matthew
stafford
you know solid defensive play throughout
the day where a defense that i would say
is not that talented and not that
special but uh to go into philadelphia
and find a way to win that football game
uh i think it says a lot about matt
patricia and where the lines are at yeah
and i agree with you and and look they
they viewed that first game of the
season as a loss even though it was a
tie and they overcame it and they moved
on and it feels weird to call the team
undefeated when they aren't they don't
have a perfect record right but they
still are undefeated undefeated and they
move forward and they get the chiefs
this weekend all right you know we've
talked about a lot of the games in this
spot so i don't want to cover old
grounds so i'm gonna i'm gonna say that
one of the biggest sunday statements
came from tom brady but it wasn't
anything he did on sunday it was what he
tweeted on thursday night complaining
about all of the penalties because they
had a conference call on saturday night
among the officials they talked about
holding and all the holding penalties
we've seen throughout the first two
weeks plus that extra game titans
jaguars as a result according to
espn.com
the
holding penalties per game plummeted
from 5.7
through thursday night yeah to 2.9 wow
yesterday wow so big statement from
tommy tommy brady with his twitter
account influencing the national
football league along with everybody
else who was complaining about it right
but tom brady makes the sunday statement
his sunday statements are so strong he
doesn't even have to make him on sunday
yeah and uh and you know this holding
penalty
we see this every year
free advice to the nfl
apply a little foresight sometimes so
instead of having to clean up a mess two
weeks into the season like roughing the
passer penalties last year holding this
year let's get it right before the
season starts yeah can't we so because
when you do this right you do undermine
the integrity of the season because the
first 33 games of the year
were called
under the heightened standards yes and
now you're putting a different standard
out there for the other 223 games of the
year that necessarily affects the
integrity of the full season yeah it is
annoying i mean that's uh it's annoying
almost as annoying as you're picky there
for a nonsense that's all right that
happens
apparently you will but a tweet on
thursday makes it as a sunday but the
point was a good one the point is good
the point is that yes it was getting out
of hand and there was too many holding
penalties where it had nothing to do
with the play you're like wait the ball
is 40 yards to the right and we're
calling a holding on the left hash on
the other side of the field what the
hell are we doing that's where it
started to drive me crazy had no
influence on the play so horrible pick
by you great point by you horrible pick
by you you lose the draft automatically
with that pick automatically default
okay now getting back to go ahead go
ahead talk for three more minutes about
something you're right i'm like wait
wait wait i totally lost my train of
thought here because i wanted to cry my
next biggest sunday statement okay is
going out to san francisco with stats
san francisco 49ers yes that's a big
statement the 49ers with the bye week on
the horizon going into that into the bye
week now 3-0 i mean that's pretty
beautiful and then not only 3-0 but to
go 3-0 in a game at-home home opener
where you just play sloppy football and
you're playing a desperate pittsburgh
team and it was sloppy but yet not
sloppy i mean the offense was phenomenal
with the nor i mean with the san
francisco 49ers but you know hey
interceptions yeah some of the
quarterback fall you know some little
tough luck the fumbles i mean the
steelers were hitting out there but the
49ers weathered the storm and found a
way to get a big turnover for themselves
there at the end of the game to set them
up for the game-winning touchdown but
the 49ers mike i mean a little like some
of the other teams we've talked about
they're kind of finding their way still
and they're not playing their best
football but they're 3-0 and they got a
lot of things about the team that you go
ooh these are the type of things in your
dna that make teams good great offensive
line great defensive line run the ball
on anybody uh and just because of those
three aspects right there it makes it
hard it makes them able to match up with
any team in football if you hated my
last pick you're going to despise oh
here we go
i'm going back to next for this sunday
this was a statement made on sunday
right literally a statement made on
sunday antonio brown is done with the
nfl as part of a tweet storm that we saw
yesterday morning turn on any news
channel today and they're going to talk
about that before they talk about
anything that happened on the field that
continues to be the dominant storyline
in the nfl as much as we're sick of it
and and it feels like we're at a point
where although who knows with antonio
brown he's always one tweet away from
turning things upside down again he says
he's done with the nfl
the thinking is he really isn't done
with the nfl but he was cut friday night
as of saturday three teams were
interested they wanted to wait to see
what happened with the investigation
that was pending against him that is
still pending against him that will
still unfold in the coming days and
weeks no one is going to touch him until
that investigation is concluded and now
he says he's done with the nfl and when
you start taking shots at people like
the owner of the team you most recently
played for
your next team may be thinking twice
because whoever employs him now is
stepping into the spot of being the next
future target of antonio brown so who
knows what's going to happen going
forward but he made a big statement
right in a variety of different ways on
sunday on twitter a couple hours before
the game started all right one more okay
at least i'll take that on sunday i mean
at least it was
said that the the officials made this
statement by not throwing so many home
penalties i wanted to give tom brady
credit because i think it did you've
done a phenomenal job of not talking
about football during we talked about it
oh good job not talking about football
go ahead and go here we go sunday
statement
number three the packers
we've already talked about it yeah give
me something we haven't talked about i
defy you for your last pick something we
haven't talked about already today well
is there a game we haven't really hit on
yet i don't know if there really is okay
i mean
uh my it's down to the bills or the
cults that's who i want to say and i'm
gonna go with the colts okay i don't
know if we talked about that in much or
not but i'm gonna tell talk about it
either way because they made a statement
oh one in one colts and yeah we're not
sure what their team is and it's no
andrew luck and oh we lost to the
chargers in week one and just found a
way to win in week two against the
titans well they didn't just find a way
to
win in week two against the titans first
off that's when i texted you on friday
that i was mad i took the falcons
because i watched the film last week of
the colts versus the titans and i went
oh my gosh the colts are going to beat
the the atlanta falcons there's no doubt
in my mind uh but either way it was a
statement with what they did on sunday
everybody i think you know hey falcons
high sh you know high flying falcons
coming into town matt ryan they got a
win on sunday night against the eagles
watch out you know can the colts really
compete and win this type of football
game well yeah they competed and jacobi
percent was phenomenal and he's showing
that yeah why the colts might not be
like the chiefs or the patriots in the
afc they're that next level team down to
where i'd go watch out and they're
certainly playoff caliber and i'd watch
out at having to play them in the
playoffs just like we talked about with
the 49ers i mean the the one thing with
the colts so they'll never be outmatched
is they're all lines as good as anybody
in football and their d-line is as good
is really versatile and good too so that
was a big statement they're two and one
i win the draft
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports